[Applause]
good afternoon and welcome today we are
privileged to be hearing a timely
address about the European Union
delivered by Austrian President
Alexander van der Belen I'd like to
recognize Colombia's European Institute
for co-sponsoring this event and to
thank professor Jack Snyder for
moderating the question and answer
period session that will follow the
president's remarks I also want to
acknowledge the Austrian officials who
are traveling today with the president
welcome all of you to Colombia
I have noticed something of a trend
among the world leaders we are welcoming
to Colombia this week several were
academics before entering politics
experienced that in this forum at least
we believe is ideal president Vander
Belen is among that group for decades
before entering politics he lived and
worked in academic communities having
much in common with this one he served
the University of Vienna as the Dean of
the faculty of social and economic
sciences and prior to that he was a
noted economist than a faculty member at
the University of Innsbruck born in
Vienna to a Russian father and an
Estonian mother President Van der Belen
is a naturalized Austrian citizen and a
self-described quote child of refugees
his family was displaced twice from
Russia in 1919 and then from Estonia in
1940 when the Soviet Union occupied the
country President Van der belen has
expressed his gratitude to Austria for
being the country that provided a safe
harbor and then a home for his family
he began his career in politics in 1994
when he was elected to Parliament as a
member of Austria's Green Party the
president then led the Green Party for
more than a decade chose to leave the
party in 2008 last year he was elected
to the presidency as an independent in a
very close election against far-right
nationalists norbert offered president
vander Belen's success was followed by
victories of centrist candidates in the
netherlands and then france who also
defeated far-right opponents some of
you'd these events as signaling the
reversal of a nativist
tide in europe and an affirmation of the
internationalism that inspired the
european union's formation in the first
place yet others are less sanguine about
the meaning of these election results
citing the narrowness of the victories
the unfolding consequences of the brexit
vote and the continuing strength of
nationalist political movements this is
a pivotal and an uncertain moment for
Europe it is perhaps worth noting that
the title of the president's talk this
afternoon EU and ever closer Union is
punctuated with a question mark the
future of Europe and the European Union
is a topic that demands our attention we
are very fortunate to have as our guest
today a leader who is one of the people
determining that future please join me
in welcoming the president of austria
alexander van der della
[Applause]
Thank You professor Bollinger for this
very kind introduction good afternoon to
all of you who gathered here special
feeling for me to be back on stage at
the University sometimes I miss it I can
tell you I was about 50 as you mentioned
when I sort of changed house and went in
into politics whether that was a good
idea is an open question but as a
president of a small or medium-sized
country within the European Union I just
would like to share with you some of my
reflections opinions convictions of
Europe's future role in the world and
afterwards of course there is room for
the discussion if you want to you know
for centuries Europe Europe's history
was a history of recurring conflicts
Wars all the time and in fact it was not
until World War two ended and the abyss
of the Holocaust that the understanding
matured in Western Europe that only
peaceful cooperation among the European
states would allow Europe citizens to
enjoy a positive present and future
this was also founded on the idea that
very close economic this event and I
think it was a it was a success also it
was interesting now at the general
meeting General Assembly meeting of the
United Nations to notice that in the in
the opening speech of General of
Secretary General to Tarrasch climate
change in the fight against it was his
second point the first one was of course
about conflict prevention prevention of
Wars and so on but the second important
point was climate change president macro
or France yesterday chaired a high-level
meeting also in the United Nations about
what was the official title I think
trying to to construct to develop a
Global Compact for environmental
protection and in particular climate
protection and today I'm just coming
from meeting with the former Mayor
Bloomberg and and his his organization's
again on climate change in this case
focusing what can the private sector do
what is the role of the private sector
what are the lower of thanks and so on
in financing these investments this is
just an example I think that shows that
our future in this important issues lies
in cooperation and not in confrontation
at least in the European Union I think
all the major challenges field flight
and migration climate change energy
policy unemployment and poverty war and
displacement violence and terror or the
digital transformation all of these
issues cannot be resolved through a
single country approach another example
that shows the necessity of some kind of
transnational organization in Europe he
is the possible abuse of market power
the possible abuse of market power by
huge firms like I'm saying the possible
abuse firms like Google Microsoft Apple
Facebook and so on who is able to
negotiate with them or bring them to
court and find new rails rules of the
game there is only one institution that
can do that and that is the European
Commission the European Commission has
the power to know how the strange also
their financial strength to do something
like that no individual country by
itself could do that not certainly not
Austria but I think Germany for instance
is also not big enough
[Music]
let me add some perhaps a bit pathetic
words the European Union is not only an
economic community it is I hope also
community of values or I should say more
exactly it should be a community of
values forming sort of a compass to
determine the course of the journey you
know apart from the details of politics
of everyday politics with these common
European values I mean and I'm not sure
that I mean I don't want to say that
these are purely European values I'm
sure that we share them with many I'm at
the Columbia University probably with
all of you here in this room that
doesn't mean that they are universal
values like Liberty
you know libert galit a fraternity to
quote 1789 instead of fraternity would
call perps you which may call it
solidarity what I would add had
tolerance respect empathy and attention
to other people's needs these are things
that should not change when so much else
is changing these days
did not hinder my presidential campaign
to be openly in favor of human rights
and their defense I think I would I
would I want to live in a Europe that is
characterized by respect for those who
think differently who love differently
who look different and so on dear
colleagues
there are many observers including those
in the United States that have the
impression that the EU is in a crisis at
odds with itself incomplete and
vulnerable and they have a point yet I
would like to reply you know when 28
highly developed democracies democracies
have to find a common script a common
structure a common political structure
they write well that cannot be easy it
cannot be easy and it not every detail
can't remain uncontested this reaching a
consensus within the European Union is
never smooth sailing and has never been
however I'm old enough to see that the
European Union has gone through many
crises and mostly it has grown from them
for instance I remember economic crisis
in the late 70s I think beginning of the
80s we had the impression that the
European project is sort of losing its
footing we call this Iowa sclerosis you
know everything went wrong in an
economic way Europe was preceded to be
you know a couple of years later nobody
talked about that anymore
so this experience I think has fed the
conviction that European integration in
spite of various setbacks at times that
this integration will continue with a
strong determination and can no longer
be reversed more or less like a law of
nature this is of course loose thinking
it is a non sacred tool because you may
overcome 100 crises safely and the
hundred one hundred and first one is
deadly now I'm coming to the question is
the European Union and ever closer Union
do we just see the one hundred and first
crisis or is it already behind us
depends how you look at it it is true
that the European Union was long
considered to be a very attractive club
everybody who everybody in in the
greater European area wanted to be a
member of this attractive Club this
attractiveness has developed cracks
there are developments in Poland for
instance or in Hungary where the rule of
law is questioned the European member
states are divided over how to deal with
the refugee question there are some
countries again on the eastern side that
would rather not take any to take in any
refugees at all on the other hand
Germany Sweden and Austria took in more
than 1 million in 2015 alone most of
them from Syria and presently as you
probably know we have a problem of
dealing with the refugees or migrants
depends on want to call them the
migrants from Africa crossing the sea to
Italy
and of course breaks it the decision of
the majority of the British population
in favour of breaks it apparently yanked
us out of all European integration
dreams for the first time you know a
member state is now striving to leave
the club instead of getting in this was
something you could say that came as a
shock personally I consider breaks it a
serious mistake of the majority of the
British Isles a tragic error if you will
nonetheless the decision is to be
respected on the other hand this was
such a shock that I think the Europeans
take the Europe each European project
more seriously than before because
suddenly it was open you know it's not
an abstract discussion it can actually
happen that the union is breaking apart
my experience during the short
presidential campaign that lasted for
about 14 months beating American
standards concerning the length of time
you know I did not leave the slightest
doubt from the beginning of my
pro-european convictions and approach
and that was rather hard going before
the brexit decision because nobody was
very interested in European questions
after the breaks it it was immediately
totally different especially among the
young people whereas my opponent or his
party even after the breaks decision
briefly Koide via with the idea of
Austria leaving the European Union
before they realized that this is
totally unpopular
in Austria following that think of the
French elections
McCrone achieved the sparkling election
result with a clearly European program
the people in France might perhaps want
another Europe they want change within
Europe but they do not want no Europe
and regardless how in detail the
elections will go in Germany the
Bundestag elections are becoming Sunday
I am convinced that Germany will
continue its pro-european course - which
makes an interesting starting point for
the next years because the the French
German axis was always important
either way to bring new momentum into
the process or to block everything
an interesting sign of the change of the
change of mood within the European Union
was are the speeches by jean-claude
Juncker the president of the Commission
a year ago in his State of the Union
speech at the same time in September a
year ago his speech had a strong
pessimistic undertone everything was
going down the drain this year Janka was
a different person this speech was full
of optimism he made several interesting
propositions regarding the integration
of the European Union and how to advance
it of course propositions that were
immediately criticized by the member
states of the European Union but still
you know he was optimistic enough to
propose them to make clear statements
and what makes me particularly
optimistic about the the the future of
the European Union or European Union are
the young voters the young people even
in the United Kingdom in the United
Kingdom it turns out that the majority
of the young people were in favor of
staying in favor of remaining within the
Union the problem was many didn't take
it seriously enough and didn't vote so
this is a message for some of you
perhaps also if you do not use your
voting rights that can leave as it can
can can lead to a rude awakening
afterwards when it's too late still
it's good to see that they are anxious
now the young British people are afraid
of the impact of brexit concerning their
opportunities their education
possibilities their career options the
impact of break seeds in short on a free
life of studying traveling and working
all over Europe the key message I think
of the younger generation is they do not
just believe in European they do not
just have hopes or things like that they
have a European identity and this is an
important thing I think you know it is
I'm coming from I was born in Vienna but
I consider myself to be a Tyrolean
because abroad was productive so how
many identities do I have a matter Olien
an Austrian and the European and they
have as you mentioned an Estonian mother
and a Russian father so I'm the perfect
European in a way in some sense or you
go you cross the former border go to
South Tirol of course there are
Tyroleans they are Italians and they are
Europeans they have no problems with
their identities I think this is a
prejudice of the older generation that
you run into identity problems in modern
Europe and this is also if you look at
of recent surveys even in Austria with
different one party at least always had
how shall I put it diplomatically
forget that
I just wanted to say that two-thirds of
the young people surveyed had a clearly
positive attitude toward EU and only
seven percent answered responded that
they were against membership in the
Union and as many as eighty-three
percent that surprised me of the young
people felt that they were certainly
quote unquote certainly EU citizens so
in some ways the older generation I
consider myself to be of the older
generation for us for a long time the
nation state was normality this is not
normality anymore for the young people
the European Union with all its faults
is their natural home okay thank you
very much for listening to me it was
nice to be back in university from time
to time you know I need that but now you
can ask me anything you want to a kind
of promise that I can answer every
question but I'll try thank you
Thank You president van der balan for
putting a lot of material on our plate
to chew on I'm sure that we have a lot
of students who will want to come up to
either of these two microphones and ask
you questions I understand they're a
bunch of Austrian students in the room
and since I lecture to Austrians and
students who visit from Vienna every
year I know they're Lively and we'll
have plenty to say and so as they're
lining up the microphones though I just
wanted to make one personal observation
it's really an honor for me to join my
colleagues in welcoming you to Columbia
in part because I was so warmly welcomed
in Vienna a few years ago when I
attended a meeting that was on the 200th
anniversary of the Congress of Vienna
and the some of the top officials of the
city of Vienna came and addressed our
meeting and they not only welcomed us
but at the same time they underscored
that they were welcoming the refugees
that at that time we're reaching crisis
proportions in your part of the world
and also we met with plenty of just
regular citizens of Vienna who were not
only aiding the refugees but welcomed
them into their homes and I found that
just very inspirational and I think your
own biography
and work speaks to that as well so I
appreciate the example that you're
setting for us in that regard okay we're
gonna go to our people in the audience
and so ask your question succinctly and
start off by saying your name and your
affiliation like whatever Schouler
Department EURion sure so my name is
Valerie vitani
I'm from Austria SEPA student graduating
in twenty twenty nineteen mr. president
thank you very much for speaking today
at Columbia University and thanks very
much for stressing the importance of a
strong European Union yet we see
increasing tendencies towards
nationalism and even protectionism and
populist movements that frustrates
voters on all sides of the political
spectrum so my question is how can we
assure that commitment and political
decision-making and participation gets
larger particularly on a global and on a
European level across citizens thanks
[Applause]
up to one year ago there seemed to be
common consensus between politicians and
journalists at least in Austria but also
in Germany in the Netherlands France I
think that the nationalist movement is
unstoppable
one year later it's obvious that it
wasn't true it was a sort of how do you
say that in English if we talk about
behavior of people on the stock market
in Germany you say haven't rape hurt
behavior is that the reference so
something like that exists also with
with with people from the media and of
course politicians if everybody's of
this opinion it must be true but it
wasn't I would be careful with the
expression populist this is one of the
things that is usually not defined at
all who is a populism was Martin Luther
a populist because he said you have to
look in Germany it says then fork of
small shower look at the mall in English
well whatever you know what I mean
professor I think he's in Princeton just
published a book a little book in German
trying to define what he thinks what
what populist may mean and he defines it
in the way that once you're saying that
you and you alone represent the
population and everybody else is you
know
a minority uninteresting in my case that
was what was I representatives of the
oath Willie you know whatever that means
we were proud to be utterly Thalia in
German so I prefer to talk about
nationalism not populism it is true that
in some member control countries of the
you of the Union we have that say
irritating developments like what is the
in liberal society in Hungary what does
that mean or you know the Commission is
in a serious conflict with the
government of Poland concerning the
separation of the executive power and
the judicial power and what the Polish
government wants to once it wants to
change the role of the judicial power in
favor of the executive power things like
that yes
nationalist I don't know Poland does not
want to leave the union
neither does by the way Hungary they
want to stay I don't know of a single
member country where there is a serious
movement of exiting the
okay hi go over to this side yeah thank
you for visiting my name is Sam I am a
senior at GS so your neighbor
Switzerland has never been part of the
EU and from what I garner most of their
people feel like they're part of the
European community the country is part
of the European Economic Community and
they're very integrated with Europe so
is that an option you would be willing
to give the United Kingdom or some other
EU Member State who decides to leave you
know this option of being part of the
economic community without being part of
the EU yes it could be an option the
model of Switzerland Norway is another
example as a Norway in Scandinavia but
so far the British government has not
signaled that they to seriously consider
that because Switzerland does pay into
the European budget Switzerland does in
principle except before per freedoms
including freedom of the of the working
force to move and they may government so
far does not accept free movement they
don't even they don't even have the
remain on their program not even the the
Common Market recommends an opinion act
is seems to have priority so I hope I am
NOT unfair but the problem of the
negotiations the main problem is the
negotiations between the Commission and
the megamum it seems to be that nobody
really knows what the British government
wants to do this makes it really
difficult
for Switzerland to come back to the
question could be a model whether the
British want it I don't know
thank you okay back to this side second
hipness president dear president my name
is Juliet fajas I'm also from Austria
although I very much identify with the
kind of European identity that you
mentioned my question is regarding more
of a monetary integration so
specifically I want to know your opinion
on a shared European debt and what do
you think that the creation of your
bones could actually increase social
cohesion in Europe thank you
when the euro was introduced I was
advocating it with severe reservations
that I kept on myself because if you are
familiar with the theory of the optimum
currency area robot Montell it's obvious
that the eurozone is not an optimal
occurrences own so in that case you
would have to have either a strong
mobility within the working force which
I don't think we have in Europe I mean
of course the intellectually very if you
formally very well educated and have
practical experience the European market
is open your job market is open for you
but for everybody else is not that easy
or you would have some kind of internal
financial discipline finish some kind of
financial balance within the state we do
not have that within the European Union
so the the Euro from the start I said I
think had some what we call deep woods
Fela some mistakes by birth if you
translate that verbally which did not
did did not hinder the Euro to be a
success internationally however if you
look at Italy and Greece some countries
have difficulties of coping with a
common common currency Austria doesn't
I'm always saying somewhat cynically
perhaps but it's true because we
trained for a common currency decades
before the euro was introduced because
the shilling at the time was bound to
the development to the exchange rate of
the game German day mark so you could
say that the only thing that changed for
Austria was the telephone number in
Frankfurt nothing else but if you're not
used to that if the employees unions and
employees the labor unions until
employers unions are not used to that
particular regime you sooner or later
you get difficulties with your with your
[Music]
competitiveness greece again is a very
special case whether they have the euro
or not i think is a secondary question
their problems are of another of another
quality did I answer your question on
which our the sheer depth shared you
repeat European debt years ago which
even Yunker he wasn't in the commission
at the time he was still I think prime
minister of Luxembourg but from the of
she's from the Conservative Party
European Conservative Party Younker
endorsed this idea of shared European
debt with the special form of red pants
and blue bonds that was the idea that is
European states that's often of English
like viable for a liable a liable for
the European depth only up to what was
the thing 50% 60% according to the
Masters kathiria of of public depth but
not for the depth that for instance the
Italians or the Greek authorities
whoever issues presumably beyond that
point the idea I think was good but the
opposition was too strong the opposition
in particular in Germany and I am really
an admirer of mrs. Merkel as far as the
European policies in general is
concerned and for many other things too
but the fiscal ideas of Finance Minister
Sharon were part of the problem not of
the solution in the last 10 years
thank you thank you thank you for being
here could you state your name and
affiliation Thanks
right my name is ingerbord Sharda I am
doing the sustainable finance degree
here at the Earth Institute and thank
you very much for bringing up climate
change a number of climbers because at
the federal levels
that tends not to occur Europe is now
being seen as taking a leading role on
ensuring that climate change mitigation
and adaptation gets funded and
progresses but it's falling short of
what needs to happen hmm how do you see
what what mechanisms do you see for
encouraging more ambition in the
European Union to reach something even
approaching a limit of two degrees of
warming question like that used to be a
cause for severe depression on my part
because you know I started doing
seminars and lectures at the University
and climate change and what economists
think about it in I think in the early
or early 80s or in the middle of the 80s
at the latest
so if economists realize here is the
serious problem the climatologists must
have worked on it 30 years already so 30
years now again 30 plus 30 years it's at
least 60 years since the phenomenon is
known and we have done almost nothing
about it that was is the depressive
message the optimistic message is before
the Paris agreement only few people
believe that in Paris will make a
difference in 2015 it did make a
difference I'm really I'm really I hope
I do hope it's not only I'm not only
hoping it I have the impression you know
especially after as I told you after the
General Assembly meeting of the United
Nations here this is a prime topic on
the United Nations level concerning
developed countries as well as the less
developed
work you are right of course that it's
very much of it is paper declarations
and paper on the on the on the actual if
you look at what what what really is
done the messages is less clear but I
think the the people perceive it
differently the attitude has changed the
attention certainly has changed it is
not a matter of green parties anymore it
is a matter for Bloomberg for instance
you know and even in the United States
no matter was the the present federal
administration says on the regional and
on the local level there's a lot going
on and this is very important so America
I am told I'm not sure whether it's true
or not might might achieve might might
get the obligations of fulfill the
obligations under the Paris arrangement
even if the federal government hasn't
wanted to because of the engagement of
on the regional and local level so we're
getting pretty close to the time when we
need to stop on the other hand we want
to hear at least some of your questions
so what I'd like to do if it's all right
is take three more very succinctly
then go back to president Vander Belen
to answer whatever in there we have time
I guess to know the message you have to
be shorter yeah okay so six sync
questions thanks mr. president mr.
president thank you so much my name is
Alex la snack I'm a junior at Columbia
College we heard in your introduction
that you will remember the Green Party
but left it to run as an independent and
the question I want to ask you is
whether you think that parties and
candidates on the Left need to turn
further to the left towards socialism or
social democracy type platforms in order
to beat the far right in Western
democracies debate that we have here in
the US and other countries Thank You mr.
president and Erica junior in Columbia
College as well you mentioned you are
being a community of values and you
subsequently mentioned the situation
currently going on in Poland and Hungary
I'm just wondering what you think would
be Europe's what Europe can do and was
its willing to do and specifically what
the role of national government is in
relation to the role of European
Commission thank you and last question
over here apologies to the others who
didn't get in good afternoon mr.
president again thank you for speaking
my name is Antonia Greenberg and I'm a
senior in Columbia College earlier in
your address you mentioned the usability
as a community to take on tech giants
like Google like Apple and Google in
particular has had some contentious
dealings with the European states in
light of election interference and
recurring questions of cybersecurity
what level of integration would the EU
be comfortable with in tackling issues
of cybersecurity what risks are involved
will they have to sacrifice and would it
ultimately be effective to have a United
cybersecurity digital front
candidates I think well it is true that
I ran as a sort of independent candidate
but everybody knew that I had been a
member of a parliament for the Green
Party everybody knew in Australia there
had been a chairman of the Green Party
for eleven years and so on it was more
of an organizational question because it
was clear you know the Greens in Austria
at best in the last years with the last
20 or 30 years we would think of a 15
percent share of words the president has
to run for 51 percent of the votes
so it made no sense to run as a purely
green candidate I'm not sure what the
message is for other countries what I do
think is if you look at France for
instance that the role of personalities
is getting stronger and stronger and the
programme that the political affiliation
or so the concrete program is is
gorgeous
it seems to me less important than it
ever was has probably something to do
with the how should I put it
old old class borders are vanishing so
people are orientating orienting
themselves according to other rules
quote unquote
for instance personalities since this
seems to be true
what maybe less you know I'm not sure
what what the result would be if you if
you look at the if specific countries
for instance in Germany the situation is
different party affiliation who seems to
be very strong values Poland and the
economic commission the conflict is not
if the conflict is going on if I
remember the rules correctly in the
worst case in the worst case Member
State who does not follow the rules can
be music man doesn't have any voting
rights anymore
but for that you need unanimity of the
other member states and nobody seems to
believe that Hungary would go along with
such a world but we are not in we are
not yet at least
at this stage the Polish President mr.
Duda vetoed the last legislation of the
Polish Parliament so he now has to
present another proposal and we'll see
how the other whether that will ease the
conflict with the Europe European
Commission the last question is
difficult for me because I'm absolutely
no expert in internet cybersecurity and
all that
I'm not really worried about
cybersecurity if you live in a country
with democratic rules where this where
the rule of law prevails the problem is
how can you be sure that even if you
live at the moment in such a country
that it stays that way recently I made a
remark to a friend of mine that I feel
comfortable then I realize that for
instance in China if you take advice of
you you get they have some sort of app
where you will see where the next
bicycle is standing you take that pass
you can write it let it stand and so on
and we're going to experiment with that
in Vienna - of course where you go how
long you take and so on suddenly is part
of the Internet I complained about that
and then my friend took away my mobile
and showed me where I was the last three
days I didn't even know that that was
sort of part of the data you know two
hours ago I met with representatives of
Alibaba the Chinese company very
interesting for instance the idea is
they have hundreds of millions of
customers so they can they have a good
basis for s4 for an for an estimate how
solvent a client is now this could be an
important information for instance if
you want to have a visa Schengen visa
for the European area
hmm do we rely on this information as
European authorities or do we not in
principle I think it's a seems to be a
sensible idea but it's a private firm of
course on the other hand I wouldn't
exclude it out of hand because this is
an important market we are talking about
300 million possible tourists coming to
the European Union if you look at the
world in total I think the Europeans try
Europeans they try hardest to get some
to get a real separation between private
information that is only for me
information about me that is for me only
and other nations that are said let's
say less
are not so anxious about the misuse of
information about private life I'm in
that respect I'm a conservative for
better or worse so thanks for sharing
your thoughts here I have to say you're
something of a hero
precisely because you've been one of the
people who have been effective at
standing and resisting the herd behavior
that you were talking about before so
we're grateful for the chance to learn
from you enough to hear the
[Applause]
thank you
and all the best for your studies take
it seriously
[Applause]